I've been talking to you about the
importance of the census for a while and
it's not a sexy topic it's not very
exciting but it's really really
important so that's why I've been
talking about it and I've told you about
the Trump administration sort of
indirect or maybe direct attempt to
sabotage the census by just under
funding the Census Bureau
at every opportunity and this really
matters because it determines not only
how districting is done and how many
representatives each state gets but it
also impacts distribution of funds it
impacts representation of minority
groups and minority voters it's a really
important thing and the Trump
administration is now further trying to
torpedo the census the Commerce
Department and Commerce Secretary Wilbur
Ross have announced yesterday that the
2020 census will ask people if they are
American citizens this is of course
supported by Attorney General Jeff
Sessions and of course supported by
Donald Trump and it is an unmitigated
disaster this will do a couple of
different things number one you ask
people about their citizenship on the
census and it is going to hold down the
response rates from people who are
concerned about their immigration status
meaning that they will be
underrepresented in the census and you
can imagine how hugely impactful that is
when you ask about citizenship on the
census you are doing something that is
also redundant and not necessary there's
this thing called the American Community
Survey which asks about citizenship
already the census hasn't asked about
citizenship since 1950 you have a
president who ran on and continues to
threaten to do deportations to round
people up humanely as he likes to say to
build walls and then you put a
citizenship question on the census you
think you're going to get accurate data
in that way if you want to skew the
survey to out under count minorities and
immigrants for political gain this is
exactly what you do you put a
citizenship question on the census with
we'll make it so that anyone concerned
about immigration status simply does not
participate and now it's becoming part
of a bigger strategy it's a more
coherent strategy now to torpedo the
census underfund the census at a high
level and then add a question about
citizenship not every state is taking
this line down California is suing over
this decision very good example by the
way California of a blue state with a
high immigrant and minority population
that will get screwed out of a ton of
money if you include this question in
the census and one of the reasons that
the trumpet administration the Trump
administration Wilbur Ross whoever one
of the reasons that they're giving for
putting this question back in is hey we
had this question in the census from the
1800's to 1950 can you imagine using
that logic for anything else hey they
had slavery during that time we should
do we should we should put that back in
they had legal discrimination during
that time let's add that back in as if
that's a reason to do things the fact
that we used to do something can't be in
a modern Western democracy supposedly
modern supposedly a democracy a reason
for doing something like this and it's
actually really representative of what
conservatism wants right we've talked
about this before on many issues we say
conservatives want to go back to the
1950s on some issues they want to go
back to the 1850s altogether and this
includes you know take your choice of
issues where they want to regress
whether it's women's rights or LGBT
rights or many many others so this is
it's one of those ideas that to the
Trump is right will sort of sound like
yeah why why would anyone have a problem
with that if you're here legally then
you have nothing to be afraid of and if
you're not here legally you shouldn't be
here at all and you shouldn't be part of
the census so we don't have to worry
about it this is a way to shift funds
from big blue states including states
like California and New York to red
states with lower populations that will
be proportionately or in proportion more
represented by the census if
you had this question hopefully
California succeeds in their lawsuit and
other states follow